foreign
people we are live on the internet I'm
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report and
we've got another Friday Roundtable
Extravaganza for you we're doing
something special today only two guests
that's right well two plus me am I a
guest on my own show three of us instead
of the normal four on Friday joining me
today is the opinion editor at Newsweek
Josh hammer and the editor-in-chief of
the post-millennial Libby Emmons Josh
Libby how are you crazy kids
Dave shabbat shalom great to be back
with you my friend shabbat shalom my
friend Libby how are you I'm doing well
thanks it's good to have you guys on I
should note up top that uh Josh every
week now there's another hit piece
dropped by the Southern Poverty Law
Center or Media Matters or somebody on
you often the hit pieces include me so
I'm very excited that Libby can be part
of it too and we can definitely get some
hit pieces written about us after what
we say today so that's the that's the
theme of the show today
that's exciting would that table set
like that I guess the expectations are
very high let's see if we can match them
let's see if they can do Tucker level
work with us today uh basically we're
going to recap uh the week there's so
much happening right now between these
Biden files and more Twitter files and
just general covid craziness as people
are realizing the vaccines just simply
did not work and actually may have done
more damage than good so let's get right
into it uh the the Twitter files really
have been the main uh thing over the
last couple weeks just we're learning
about government censorship we're
learning about cover-ups we're learning
about collusion with uh not only big
Tech but corporate media and the whole
freaking thing uh Matt taibi who is uh
who is a lefty journalist or at least
has been a lefty journalist his whole
life he is one of the guys uh that Elon
Musk has been leaking these Twitter
files to he had a long thread yesterday
about russiagate and of course
russiagate which ultimately led to
Donald Trump being impeached and a whole
bunch of other things uh it basically
sounds like the entire thing was a
complete Fab fabrication so he had a
crazy long thread we picked just some of
the highlights so bear with me as I read
some of these for you here and and then
we'll go from there so uh thread Twitter
files 14 the russiagate lies the fake
tale of Russian Bots and the hashtag
release the memo hashtag at a crucial
moment in a years-long fewer Democrats
denounced a report about flaws in the
trump-russia investigation saying it was
boosted by Russian Bots and trolls
Twitter officials were aghast finding no
evidence of Russian influence we are
feeding Congressional trolls not any
significant activity connected to Russia
putting the cart before the horse
assuming this is propaganda slash Bots
these are obviously quotes from Twitter
employees four Twitter warned
politicians and media the that not only
they lacked evidence but had evidence
the accounts weren't Russian and were
roundly ignored
on January 23 2018 Senator Dianne
Feinstein and congressman Adam Schiff
published an open letter saying the
hashtag gained the immediate attention
and assistance of social media accounts
linked to Russian influence operations
Connecticut Senator Richard Blumenthal
followed suit publishing a letter saying
we find it reprehensible that Russian
agents have so eagerly manipulated
innocent Americans
couple more for you Feinstein Schiff
Blumenthal and media members all pointed
to the same Source the Hamilton 68
dashboard created by former FBI
counterintelligence official Clint Watts
under the auspices of the alliance for
securing democracy the dashboard which
featured a crude picture of Vladimir
Putin deviously blowing evil red Twitter
Birds into the atmosphere was vague in
how it reached its conclusions
I encourage you to be skeptical of
Hamilton's 68's take on this which as
far as I can tell is the only source for
these stories said Global policy
Communications Chief and future White
House and NSC NSC spokesman Emily horn
she added it's a comms play for ASD
couple more here Roth couldn't find any
connection to the release the memo at
all I just reviewed the accounts that
posted the first 50 tweets with hashtag
release the memo and none of them show
any signs of affiliation to Russia when
Twitter spoke to a Blumenthal staffer
they tried to wave him off because we
don't believe these are Bots Twitter
Executives even tried to negotiate
implying an undisclosed future PR
concession if Blumenthal would lay off
on this it seems like there are other
wins we could offer him Blumenthal
published his letter anyway
execs eventually grew frustrated over
what they saw as circular as a circular
process presented with claims of Russian
activity even when denied led to more
claims eventually Twitter staff realized
Blumenthal isn't looking for real and
nuanced Solutions but just wants to get
credit for pushing us further NBC
political AP times Business Insider and
other media Outlets who played up the
Russian bot story even Rolling Stone all
declined to comment for this story
meaning the Twitter files and finally
the staffs of Feinstein Schiff and
Blumenthal also declined to comment okay
so I know I got a little in the weeds
there on reading a long Twitter file but
in essence
the Russian bot Story the Russian
collusion story it was all made up and
not only was it all made up
the people that were pushing it Diane
Feinstein Adam Schiff Blumenthal
basically the entire Democrat machine
which ultimately led to two impeachments
certainly the first one
um it was all complete nonsense and they
knew it Josh
what's the deal with that
so there's a lot to unpack here Dave I I
guess towards the end of the tweets that
you that you were reading there there
was one line where I guess someone at
Twitter was concluding that oh dick
Blumenthal the senator from Connecticut
might not be interested in particularly
nuanced solutions to complex problems
you know I'm not sure that it required
this level of kind of getting under the
hood to on to understand that dick
Blumenthal in particular let alone Adam
Schiffer Dianne Feinstein all these
other kind of just Democratic hucksters
are not particularly interested in
looking at things for what they are and
the Russian collusion hoax in particular
you know I I I I legitimately think it
is non-exaggeration to say that it is a
top three arguably number one hoax that
has been foisted upon the American
people by the entirety of what the late
grid Angela codavilla famously referred
to as our ruling class as kind of our
ruling Elites who control all the
institutions whether it is the law
enforcement apparatus whether it is the
social media oligarchs you know the
Twitter regime prior to Elon much they
have all been complicit in this lie and
this lie ultimately goes back of course
to Fusion GPS the infamous thoroughly
discredited steel dossier it was bought
and paid for Hillary Clinton 2016
campaign funded opposition research it
it has been garbage garbage garbage
since day one and you know I I guess
personally I am thoroughly unsurprised
that Twitter did not do more you know
that's what that is what Matt taibi is
revealing here did not do more to push
back against these Democratic efforts to
quash the Devon Nunez memo I'm
unsurprised at that because you know the
entire Jack Dorsey Twitter regime prior
to Elon Musk was obviously also bought
and paid for by the Democratic party so
unfortunately I'm unsurprised but you
know I continue to be grateful to Elon
Musk for leaking I think Dave you said
we're on Twitter file number 14. it's
been a little hard to keep up but keep
them coming I mean this is good stuff so
you know the board transparency the
better
Libby is the bigger issue that
finding all this information out just
sort of confirms what a lot of us kind
of believed and that some people were
reporting on but we didn't have the
exact Smoking Gun but that this will not
convince anyone who did not believe it
in the first place I said to you guys
right before we started I don't know
since the Twitter files have started and
we are on Twitter files 14. I don't know
if one mainstream media member won
Democrat politician one left-leaning
pundit that has come around and said boy
this was pretty bad related to kovid and
Russia and collusion and government
stepping on the First Amendment and all
that stuff I don't know anyone so where
does that put us if we just continue to
to just deviate into these separate
worlds
yeah I think that's been really
fascinating as well and there has been
something in conservative media of a
Victory lap going on with these Twitter
files as they come out and we're all
just like oh my goodness I knew it I
said this was happening
um so for us it's there's definitely
been a bit of a confirmation bias but it
has not really been reported in the New
York Times or the Washington Post we
haven't seen broad reporting of this
from the very Outlets that uh are
entirely culpable for the false
narrative that has been pushed since you
know Donald Trump threw his hat in the
ring to be president
um but before they actually do the
reverse or they do the reverse right
they tell you that it's actually a big
nothing Burger
accuracy right I mean it's very similar
to when the New York Post dropped their
reporting on Hunter Biden's laptop and
the Shady business dealings the
influence pedaling and instead of any
legitimate reporting on that subject we
saw NPR in the Washington Post the New
York Times I think CNN all of them came
out with their stories about why they
would not cover the laptop story as
opposed to actually digging into it and
looking at it CBS only just recently I
think in 2022 in the fall said oh this
is actually legitimate meanwhile you had
Emma Joe Morris and you know Jack
pesobic and a bunch of other people
saying look at the laptop I have the
laptop here it is come take it have a
gander at it for yourself the raw data
and those Outlets did not want to do
that in terms of Blumenthal who you know
is such a huckster I've watched him
testify in Congress many times or you
know ask questions
um with people who are testifying and he
is such a joke
um but what we look at too and this is
something that Elon Musk said is that
the water that the Twitter employees
were swimming in in San Francisco is
Progressive leftist Democrat biased
water and that's not surprising because
all of these people came out of the same
universities studied with the same
massively left-leaning professors we
know that if you go to a university and
you start talking about you know perhaps
the going narrative is not actually
correct you don't get as good of a grade
as you might if you just uphold The
Narrative we know that universities are
not interested in teaching facts they're
not interested in making sure that you
are studying your actual subject instead
what they want to do is indoctrinate you
they want to tell you what to think and
how to think about the world and that's
where these you know Twitter employees
came out of when you're out there
studying Tech also you're not
particularly studying ethics so you're
getting
um you're getting your your world view
and and perspective sort of second hand
from all of these things and it just
seems like it's totally normal and the
way that things are and it really takes
questioning uh questioning Authority
which is something liberals used to love
to say to actually start to get to the
bottom of things right it seems to me
you're taught how to shape the world
rather than how to understand the world
but I think you guys are an interesting
Duo to have on when we're discussing
something like this because Josh you're
the opinion editor at Newsweek so
Newsweek of course which has existed for
many decades as a fairly reputable place
of information and as editor-in-chief of
post-millennial you Libby you're doing
sort of new school more in line with
what we do here like the digital thing
but Josh you're actually helping
Newsweek sort of you know jump that that
bridge but when you talk to colleagues
at Newsweek or or mainstream colleagues
are you finding that anyone is moved by
this or what can what is it has the ship
sailed basically is what I'm asking when
it comes to Major League should we just
all go on the assumption that if CNN is
telling us anything about this it's a
lie and what they're not telling us is
actually the truth at this point
look I mean I think the corporate media
you know in part in general as a general
rule of the New York Times Washington
Post CNN you know all the usual actors
you know I think it's probably fair for
the same right of Center half of America
to mostly write them off you know you
will find some you know some nice apples
some some good seats some Diamonds in
the Rough anywhere um and Newsweek in
particular you know I mean I I the fact
that I have been an employee there for
almost three years now I think kind of
says all you need to know about kind of
intellectual openness of the current
management of that company to my boss's
great credit you know my colleagues
definitely I think have have looked at
the hunter Biden you know Affair since
day one they have looked at the Twitter
files with you know with eyes wide open
you know ready to kind of assess what is
happening I can't speak for everyone
obviously but based on my conversations
you know I think a good number of my
colleagues are willing and able to look
at what is going on here but you know I
mean what Libby said about this CBS News
I mean finally confirming literally
about two years so you know the Dr Biden
laptop store that story was broken by
the New York Post back in October 2020
right on the precipice of the election
you know has anyone apologized to the
New York Post I mean has a single person
like at CBS The New York Times or any of
these Outlets how about that that group
of 50 so-called intelligence Community
National Security Experts you know Jim
Clapper all the folks like that have any
of them like a single person actually
formally apologized to the editors on
the mask said that at the New York Post
were just throwing all of that under the
bus to mine no but Jim Clapper did get a
job at CNN so that's pretty good right
exactly exactly right and you know what
Libby said about confirmation bias is
exactly right that's kind of what I was
saying earlier about kind of this notion
of what Angela codavilla called the
ruling class you know when you go to
certain institutions when you kind of
work and grow up in a certain kind of
social milose a Silicon Valley being a
great example of that obviously you are
trained to take in certain information
and then block other information and
unfortunately that's obviously captured
all too many of our once great
institutions
yeah Libby I suppose is someone doing
New Media you view this like sort of as
net good for what you guys are building
and and I do as well actually at a
personal level but I still am worried
what it means at a societal level
because as those two Avenues just go
further and further apart
it's impossible to convince people of
anything and I have no doubt that there
are some decent people on the other side
that probably think we're all nuts I
mean I'm fairly certain we're giving
evidence of what we're talking about
here but therein lies the rub
yeah it's interesting what you say about
the you know the diverging paths and the
diverging paths politically in society
in American society right now because it
certainly did not start this Divergence
did not start with politics it started
with culture and we've been seeing this
cultural divide come for some time and
now it's taking root in politics as well
but in culture we've seen the fracturing
of our entertainment we've seen the
fracturing of our values and we've been
seeing that for more than a decade now
so it's actually no surprise that you
know some of us are watching One show on
Netflix and never even heard of the show
that everybody else is raving about on
the other side of the cultural divide
and now we have this political divide
but I think that you know one thing that
I find really interesting is when I do
talk to liberals
um for example my mother who is
incredibly liberal
um when I talk to her or other people
that I know who are of that political
persuasion they typically when you say
something to them like hey it turns out
that the entire Democratic machine has
been literally lying to the faith of the
American people for this entire time
they're like no that couldn't be right I
didn't read about it in the New York
Times and the corruption of the New York
Times
um I at the post millennial I have
slammed the New York Times over and over
again and it's because I am just so
personally disappointed with the times
which I used to read daily and on Sunday
I would spend hours drinking coffee and
luxuriating and you know their magazine
section and whatever else and I loved it
so it's disappointing to see a news
outlet with this much history with this
much Resources with bureaus
internationally all over the world uh
refusing to actually report on what's
going on in our country
um and that's the thing that it's really
hard to get past is when you listen to a
liberal person and they just don't
believe you because it just sounds so
insane and you're like you really had
you really had an evolution here it
sounds like you were actually the girl
in the in like the prototypical New York
Times commercial they'd be playing light
jazz in the background it's Sunday her
cat's there like on her head and she's
drinking coffee and oh my God I'm
learning about shoes
they you're on the you're on the right
side now all right so let's move over to
to the second topic the big thing this
week is that these classified documents
were found now at two locations related
to Joe Biden uh so a quick headline from
the daily wire uh report classified
documents found in Biden's private
office covered Iran Ukraine and UK and
now it turns out that some other
documents were found at one of his
houses that apparently at one time at
least Hunter Biden claimed to have lived
in uh so we are gonna have a uh a
special counsel looking into this here's
Merrick Garland making the announcement
U.S attorney lausch and his team of
prosecutors and agents have conducted
this initial investigation with
professionalism and speed
I am grateful to them
earlier today I saw I signed an order
appointing Robert Herr a special counsel
for the matter I've just described
the document authorizes him to
investigate whether any person or entity
violated the law in connection with this
matter
the special counsel will not be subject
to the day-to-day supervision of any
official of the department but he must
comply with the regulations procedures
and policies of the department
Mr Herr has a long and distinguished
career as a prosecutor
all right so I just want to be clear on
the Trump version of this from day one I
never thought anything was going to come
of it the President also has the ability
to declassify things the VP which Biden
was at the time does not have that
ability I also just felt like everything
they've done related to Trump always
falls through so that one was going to
fall through this one although my my
sort of intellectual side is going
nothing's going to come of it my more
conspiratorial and everything
conspiratorial becomes true side is
going oh this is how they're going to
get rid of him this is actually it
because they know they can't run him
again he's too old he has dementia
they've got to figure out a way to get
Newsome in there or something like that
so Josh do you think that the the
machine or whatever you want to call it
the the elites the the people you were
talking about before that this is the
opportunity because when Biden says I
don't know what was there I don't know
what was happening I actually do believe
him I don't think he moved the boxes
there himself I don't think he has a
freaking clue what's going on
so this is a wild story I have I have so
many thoughts on this but Chance your
Top Line question Dave I mean my short
answer is yes I mean that was the column
that I wrote literally that came out
just this morning the title of this
column was is the Deep State coming
after Joe Biden I mean that is 100 oh
there you go all right I'll share it
after the show yeah no that is that is
100 my kind of bottom line takeaway as
to what is happening here the timeline
kind of gives away the game so it was it
was apparently on November 2nd when
Sauber Robert Sauber if I was first name
correctly who was Joe Biden's personal
attorney when they first discovered
these classified documents deep in the
bowels of this Chinese Communist Party
funded you know Penn Biden Center money
laundering operation there in DC and
then apparently it was in December I
think was around December 20th that they
discovered these classified documents
you know next to that shiny prized
Corvette of Joe Biden's in his in his
infamously now locked Garage in
Wilmington Delaware so the point is
we've known about this for a while so
the obvious question then that every
American who pays attention to to this
stuff should be asking is why now why
now in January after the Kevin McCarthy
speaker battle has has finished after
the new Congress is sworn in as Joe
Biden is presumably getting geared up
for the second half of his first term
why now and you know I think Occam's
rays are the most straightforward answer
Dave is the one that you just teased
which is that there are I think there
are probably some forces in the DNC in
kind of the federal law enforce and
apparatus who want Joe Biden gone they
see that or at least they think that he
did his job in preventing the the Red
Wave and many of us Yours Truly included
thought would happen in the November
elections two months ago so I I think
from that Vantage Point Joe Biden did
his job but at this point you know he's
daughtering Joe Biden from Delaware he
doesn't have a clue what time it is he
has no idea what day of the week it is
as you properly said there and I think
the thought process here and you know
Dave don't kick me off the program there
but my best guess is that these folks
that want Biden out they probably want
your arch nemesis Gavin Newsom there in
24. that's my best guess
oh I
I mean I fully believe that I think that
where the country seems to be headed is
the great if if people thought that the
Trump Hillary Showdown was the great
Showdown the great Showdown to me really
is the Florida vs California Showdown
because that really shows which way this
country is going to go are we going to
become a communist state possibly or are
we going to be a free country and and
that maybe is The Showdown we should
have I certainly welcome that that
Showdown uh Libby to sort of Link this
though to to the previous story in terms
of the perception of all of this did you
happen to see the clip of Joy Behar on
The View talking about this a day or two
ago where basically she said we think
Trump's a liar so we think that you know
he obviously did something wrong with
his docs we don't think Biden's a liar
so it sounds like this is a setup that's
what Sunny Hosten said or something like
that and that sort of gets to what we
were talking about earlier related to
the the perception part of this and even
if they have the most Smoking Gun ever
you know a document signed by Joe by it
and saying here are the nuclear secrets
trying to go to town and here's the
naked picture of Hunter with the thing
and the Snipping kid and all that that
they will just not care
yeah I think that's right I did see that
clip
um we covered that she also was saying
that she thought uh perhaps conservative
or Republicans whatever new term
whatever had planted the documents in
his uh locked Yeah by his Corvette it's
all just so absurd and they're so intent
on getting Trump and we saw this morning
to um Kevin McCarthy talking about
perhaps he would consider uh expunging
the record on Trump's impeachments and
if you look at those impeachments both
of them were based entirely and a
hundred percent on false premises they
took this whole two years of their
January 6 committee and they found
nothing they have nothing they have
nothing on the um you know 2019
allegations that turned out to be all
entirely a fabrication and they're so
determined to make Trump pay because he
broke their brains and they cannot stand
that he broke their brain that they will
come up with any uh procession of Lies
uh and this in this clown circus that
they have created out of our political
landscape in order to try and go after
him this is the ultimate ends justifies
the means so long as they get Trump in
the end they don't care how many
um truths they have to slaughter to get
there speaking of Truth they have to
slaughter Biden's line on this has also
been that it was just a small amount of
documents as if there's a caveat and a
law like oh yeah you can move a small
amount of classified documents just They
seized empty folders from Trump's house
Earth and if this is a small amount of
documents give me that
I'm pretty sure there is a manila
envelope shortage thanks to the supply
chain issue related to Biden but here's
Peter Ducey asking Biden about all of
this and he's referencing what you
talked about Josh there's a Corvette
there so everything's got to be secure
it's okay
by classified material next year
what were you thinking
let me uh look I'm going to get a chance
to speak on all this God willing soon
but as I said earlier this week
people and by the way my Corvettes in
the lock garage okay so it's not like
you're sitting out in the street but
anyway
yes as well as my Corvette
um but as I said earlier this week
people know I take classified documents
or classified materials seriously
so stupid like he's so muddled and he
reads very poorly the statement right
after that but like the garage saying
the garage is locked everyone keeps
their crap in the garage that's what you
keep in the garage if someone was going
to break into my house and they would
ask me before and hey which room would
you prefer you break into I would say
the garage that's all the crap I have
all the plastic cups in there and the
the seasonal
Josh yeah yeah but compare the garage to
where Trump was allegedly storing these
documents in Mar-A-Lago which was in a
skiff and you know this difference
between an ex-president and an ex-vice
president which you hinted at earlier
Dave this makes all the difference in
the world so you know I'm a lawyer by
background I'll do the whole
constitutional law thing just for a
second here so article two of US
Constitution invests the executive power
in one person in the president of the
United States and the president of the
United States alone what that means is I
said in my column this morning is that
the vice president has no more executive
power properly construed than any other
cabinet official or frankly than a White
House janitor so the vice president is
completely is completely incapable of
making any kind of spot declassification
classification decisions Barack Obama
when he was president could have made
those decisions Joe Biden now that he's
president can make those decisions but
when Joe Biden was vice president he had
no power whatsoever and another thing
that every Office of the ex-president
and has you know being a former
president of the United States is a
pretty big deal you get kind of lifelong
Secret Service protection and you get
this skiff to host personal copies of
your records from your time at the White
House vice presidents again do not get
that so this distinction is a big big
big difference there and you know
frankly after kind of the first
revelation at the Penn Biden Center
earlier this week and my reaction was
like a little muddled I was like okay
this is like really really bad but you
know I'm told by the mainstream media
that it's not a ton of that it's not a
ton of documents now after yesterday's
news with these two tranches of
documents that there were a bunch in the
garage and apparently there was one
other document they found elsewhere in
the house I I really do think this is
considerably worse considerably worse
than what happened to president Trump
given all that we just said there and
obviously yes the world saw you know
Mar-A-Lago got this unprecedented FBI
pre-dawn raid Joe Biden's Corvette
garage Wilmington Delaware has received
no such treatment at all Libby if you're
Biden right now and I get it you're
probably just you know wondering what
time the pudding comes in but if you're
someone related to Biden that you and
you like Joe Biden are you basically
just trying to find the Fall Guy now
because Joe obviously himself did not
move the documents right he didn't pick
up the box and put them there I have no
doubt even even if you give him all the
cognitive skills that he doesn't have
that he had nothing to do with it
directly that that would be my fair
guess but do you think they're just
running around going okay who do we have
to get to take the fall for this is it
literally like the moving guy or is it
that Hunter somehow did it or somebody
else
yeah they're gonna look for someone to
take the fall for Biden unless as you
suggest they want Biden to take the fall
for this one
um you know if they really want to get
them we're going to see a new groping
allegation come out that's how they
really go take people down we look at
what happened to uh Andrew Cuomo which I
think I could have something of a test
case going on here or they announce the
cognitive stuff I think it's one of
those two but they they don't I don't
think they want him to run in 2024 I
don't think he's capable of running in
2024. the question is who would they get
to replace them and if it's someone like
Gavin Newsom
um and they continue to manipulate media
and manipulate perception and we're in a
lot of trouble because that man has
completely destroyed California and his
next step would be to destroy the United
States
I want to be very clear about my
feelings about this if Gavin Newsom runs
for president I'm literally devoting my
life to destroying him and destroying
his campaign he will not export that
evil [ __ ] not to my free state of
Florida or any of these other good
places I do not like Gavin Newsom in
case people didn't know how I feel about
that all right let's let's shift to uh
one more story for the week because
there was a clip that went viral I
wanted to play it all weekend we got
distracted with some other things but
it's a really really fascinating clip uh
Patrick Bet David uh who is a finance
guy and has a really fantastic podcast
uh he had uh Neil deGrasse Tyson on it
Neil deGrasse Tyson is I guess what we
would call a science Communicator he
goes on Bill Maher all the time he's the
sort of darling of the mainstream media
to explain science to people sort of in
the Bill Nye the Science Guy mold and uh
and he talks about physics and astronomy
and a whole bunch where he's sort of a
modern day Carl Sagan kind of thing and
he went on Patrick's podcast and they
started talking about vaccines and
efficacy and personal responsibility and
it's a really really great moment here
the clip's about a minute long what's
your own body your own body if you want
to get an abortion get an abortion if I
want to get the vaccine I get to choose
so you can't force if I can't force you
to get an abortion you shouldn't be able
to force it because it's not about you
it's about people you interact with and
that's the social contract of public we
don't we don't even know if the vaccine
worked or not at the time yes that's
what the trials are dude that's why
these childhood are you missing data out
but but let me ask you a question are we
saying only one type of scientists are
right no we're saying that the system in
place the 16 000 that's signed up no no
the system in place to test vaccines
there's an entire system that's in place
that that with review boards and all of
it and the average that's in place now
you can say you can what you can say is
I I have a better idea than all these
review boards and all these agencies and
the CDC I have a better idea here's what
you should do and that would have made
everything better okay you can put forth
that idea but what I'm saying is
in a case where you can contaminate
someone else it's not about you it's
about the collective you're assuming
Health you're assuming you're assuming
because somebody can take the vaccine uh
won't get covered which by the way I
don't need to play the clips for you to
see it where everybody said hey if you
get it you're not going to get if you
take the vaccine you're not going to get
a Rachel Maddow Joe Biden I can give you
Fouche I can give you fit and you've
seen these clips before it's not like
you've never seen it before yeah what
happened they were wrong hold on so
so
um
The Strain evolved
man there's so much more of that but I
mean Tyson basically gets demolished he
he in essence demolishes himself
Patrick's a great interviewer he wasn't
trying to get him he was actually just
laying out some facts there but I want
to start with something he said towards
the end there there's a system in place
and what that made me think is you know
Tyson is also a very well-known atheist
and I believe that people have to
believe in something one way or another
so once he took away any belief system
as an atheist he had to believe in the
system so he had to believe that the
trials and the tests and the things that
the scientists and experts said were
going to work because it is in human
nature to believe something Josh am I
just a crazy person when I say things
like that no not even remotely I mean
this is the this is the distinction
between science and scientism or
lowercase s science and capital S
science if you prefer I mean scientism
is kind of this all-encompassing kind of
quasi-theological structure of beliefs
that includes kind of you know
teleological kind of final questions I
mean that seems to be what Neil deGrasse
Tyson believes there but you know on the
more specific part of preventing
transmission there you know I I could be
wrong about this but I think either
fouchy or someone else there in the bind
Administration actually admitted on CNN
this past October that the vaccines do
not stop transmission of the virus so we
have finally gotten the point I mean you
know everyone's admitting it now I'm
pretty sure I mean even the CDC and and
HHS now if you look at their Twitter ads
they're basically admitting it in the
way they're selling the vaccines now
they're not saying that it will stop it
right so Neil deGrasse Tyson first of
all is relying on outmoded talking
points if he's still trying to kind of
Hawk the notion that the vaccine
prevents transmission where we you know
anyone who's been paying a modicum of
attention basically since the vaccines
were rolled out in 2021 has been able to
tell that they do no such thing but you
know in appealing to this broader idea
of a system and this idea of a social
contract he I think he's doing exactly
what you're saying he is Dave and you
know I mean you know not to like try to
sound like uh you know fire and
brimstone preacher or whatever but I
think that this very this obviously is
kind of a natural consequence of when
you try to view the world then you have
no account for how humans are there or
how the Sun comes up in the morning
without kind of appealing to a higher
power I mean you're going to end up
appealing to the science Capital as
science so I think you're a spot on
basically uh Libby he said something
else that I thought was a couple things
that were interesting because they were
all wrong he also said well if you have
an alternate theory in essence then you
should put that forth except all of the
people that were for hcq and monoclonal
antibodies and have about getting some
sunlight and maybe not sitting on your
fat ass and eating Chinese food all day
they were all told that their
anti-vaxxers and anti-science and
everything else by people like him
not only by people like him but by the
federal government by the five
Administration by Twitter Executives by
UL Roth they were suppressed they were
censored they were kicked off the
internet which is where all of us get
together to share our you know better
ideas but just to take off on what you
were talking about in terms of God We
have replaced god with man-made systems
and the false idol of the self and once
those systems begin to crumble and
atheists look straight into the void
um that those who are religiously
Affiliated know exists Beyond religion
they can't handle it and their entire
mental capability for assessing and
preceding the world and Society begins
to crumble into little tiny bits and
that's what we're going to see happen
increasingly as these Revelations come
out and they become perhaps impossible
to deny which I hope that they will but
in terms of the censorship we saw that
again in the Twitter files it was
distinct a parent that anything that
went against the idea that vaccines for
covid were 100 thoroughly effective with
absolutely no side effects at all
anything that went against that Mantra
was silenced and suppressed and if you
take a look back at times in history
when the United States has developed
vaccines for example for polio which was
a much more difficult and uh
dangerous disease you had the federal
government come out and say yes there
will be side effects for people though
there will be problems some people will
have problems when taking this vaccine
there will be people who die after
taking the vaccine whether because of
the vaccine or because of coincidences
that they were going to die anyway and
the government at that time I think
treated the American people like the
intelligent people that we are as
opposed to demanding that we all believe
a fairy story about systems and guidance
and efficacy that just uh has not proven
out I don't know man somehow I knew from
beat one that it was all [ __ ] you
know you turn on any TV show and you
watch commercials all day long for every
prescription drug for restless leg
syndrome or depression or your eyelashes
are too short or your ears falling off
and what do they do half of the
commercial is you're going to have
violent diarrhea [ __ ] legs you know
like all its thoughts of suicide
vomiting diarrhea it all sounds worse
than and whatever your initial problem
is but somehow with covid you know it's
like I wasn't depressed then I took this
depression pill now I'm having horrific
diarrhea and vomiting all the time I'm a
little depressed
other than medications that actually
come with the side effect of thoughts of
suicide and you're like really because I
was depressed I don't want to take the
drug and that's more depressed plus I
had just mild depression now I'm
thinking of killing myself I'm having
diarrhea I'm vomiting my legs are
freaking out like Jesus they result in
dysentery okay
so so one of the people who who has been
instrumental and I think a lot of the
wake up related to the the let's say red
pilled people of all of this is Dr
Robert Malone and Robert Malone who is
sort of famous for getting on Joe Rogan
nobody really knew who he was outside of
the science science Community before he
went on Rogan he he is basically the
inventor of our mRNA technology and he
holds more patents on mRNA technology
than anyone he had a tweet related to
all of this he put up this image he said
just putting this out there does not
need anything more and Josh this is to
your point of have these guys uh have
lied about everything Dr fauci when
people are vaccinated they're not going
to get infected Joe Biden you're not
going to get coveted if you have these
vaccinations CDC director Rachelle
wilenski vaccinated people do not carry
the virus and do not get sick msnbc's
Rachel Maddow now we know the vaccines
work well enough that the virus stops
Bill Gates everyone who takes the
vaccine is reducing their transmission
Pfizer CEO Albert borla there is no
variant that escapes the protection of
our vaccines isn't that last one the
most fascinating having just listened to
Neil deGrasse Tyson because he says well
it evolved it evolved but borla was
saying no no no no we got you covered
Josh none of these people are going to
get fired either are they
some of them are not not working at the
moment but yeah
and it just goes back to the whole idea
of confirmation bias but you know at
this point anyone who has even a modicum
of intellectual Honesty will readily
concede that the vaccines do not do what
Pfizer moderna and the various Peddlers
of these products told the American
people that they would do you know just
a month and a half ago I was at Brown
University I mean maybe the most
iconically liberal University in America
I was doing it by public health debate
with a political science Professor there
we were debating both Obamacare and
covid and even my interlocutor this very
kind of Orthodox left of center kind of
standard boilerplate kind of ruling
class guy even he conceded to me
actually that the vaccines do not
prevent transmission he was appealing to
get vaccinated on other grounds but even
he was ready to concede that you know
Dave you and I have have privately
texted about this and you know kudos to
you for not you know for not buying the
hype since day one I tragically did I
mean I did get that modernity ad back in
April 2021 I have not gotten any kind of
so-called booster since then but if
there was a way that I could unvax
myself I'm would do so in a heartbeat
because the more and more that we learn
about these side effects of these drugs
I I just have severe severe regret
frankly that I did in the first place
listen I'll be happy to give your eulogy
Daphne can we just make note of that
when uh they take out Josh I'll
Libby bring us home
I'm really glad that I never got my son
vaccinated despite the masses and masses
of pressure in New York
New York so uh instead of getting
vaccinated so that we could go to New
York City dining establishments we just
kept driving in New Jersey and we had a
great time so um yeah I'm still just
pleased that I did that or did not do
that for him I did get vaccinated like
Josh I would happily take back the facts
um and the further I get away from it
the gladder I am that I have not
succumbed to any of the continuous
booster shots it was sort of interesting
um I I was concerned that perhaps it was
the apocalypse when the pandemic began
because I'm always sort of low-key
concerned that it's the apocalypse it's
just sort of in my nature to believe
that perhaps it's all coming to a
crashing end right away
um but then after the two weeks to stop
the spread I was like okay so we're
we're done now now we've mitigated the
math history at the hospitals and then
what really did the trick for me was
when 10 000 people were allowed to show
up and in protest for black Trans lives
outside of the Brooklyn Museum in the
beginning of June after George Floyd's
death and I thought okay so 10 000
people are allowed to show up outside
the Brooklyn Museum but me and my kid
can't go to a play or a movie or into a
shop without wearing masks and then you
had Andrew Cuomo telling everyone no
contact tracing for if people have been
at protests if they've been at protest
don't ask them because that's just
that's not okay the the right to go out
and protest for black Trans lives was
more essential than all of the other
rights they had taken away from us
during that period of time absolutely
horrifying
um and we should never let anything like
that ever happen again and I think it's
a kudos to all of the people who were
reporting during that time and screaming
about it Carol Markowitz for sure uh
just saying you guys are crazy you can't
have my rights absolutely stop and back
off and it's a good thing that there
were so many people despite the
censorship censorship and suppression
who did that always happy to give a
shout out to our friend Carol Markowitz
who by the way just like me I think the
exact same week as me moved to the free
state of Florida from New York because
she couldn't take it anymore Libby I did
not know you were vaxxed as well I am
willing to I don't know if this is
possible if you guys would like me to
send you a vial of blood Josh I can
deliver it I'm heading to your area
tonight for a dinner thing uh Libby I
can have it shipped to you and then I
don't know what you do with that exactly
but yeah I'm I'm clean I'm clean so I'm
just saying a guys it was a pleasure I
enjoyed this uh this two guests instead
of three things so maybe we'll keep
doing this and I'd love to have you guys
back have a great weekend I'm gonna
continue uh with the locals Community
right now as you guys know we do a post
game wrap up where you guys can talk
directly to me ask some questions some
comments and then we'll roll into the
weekend so if you want to do that join
us at
reubenreport.locals.com I think the
direct link is right down below if
you're watching on YouTube or Rumble and
I will be back in 37 seconds
These are nice cars these are luxury
automobiles I got a whole place they're
fully loaded
they're loaded with dead hookers
[Music]